1100 miles east along the border in
Texas the crisis is also turning dire
Republican state lawmakers are calling
on Congress to act with all means
necessary come back from vacation
provide funding to address the situation
as hundreds of illegals flood the border
there everyday joining me now is Texas
lieutenant governor Dan Patrick dan
Heller congressman Castro by the way is
saying that Washington should basically
butt out yeah it's clear that we need
stronger leadership in this state to
stand up when the president or anyone
else in Washington tries to mess with
Texas so let me dressing you basically
there yeah let me tell you what the
Texas Senate passed a resolution as you
know a few weeks ago calling this a
crisis calling it an emergency telling
the president to do whatever he needs to
do Laura these people are deniers and
deceivers either they can't face the
truth or they know it and they're
deceiving the American people I like the
idea that the White House put out last
week of the president put out let's put
these people are coming across on
airplanes and flying to San Francisco
flying to Nancy Pelosi's district fly to
all these Democrat districts and they're
gonna find out what an emergency and
what a crisis it is when their
constituents complain
why should Texas why should i rizona why
shouldn't we be the brunt of all this
and have these hundreds of thousands of
people crossing you know a hundred
thousand and one month you know Laura
when I was with you last week it was the
day I was with the president in Texas
and I talked about how we have found
sixteen hundred and seventy-one dead
bodies of women children elderly where
the drug cartels bring the people across
the border leave them with no water in
the middle of nowhere to die and the sex
trafficking tonight there are thousands
and thousands of young women all over
this country who are being forced into
prostitution we have modern-day slavery
and and Laura right now somewhere in
Texas and elsewhere there's a little
girl crying because she's trapped in a
cantina
having sex with 20 men a day and can't
get out and somewhere else there's going
to be some elderly person dying they're
crying they're dying they need help and
the Democrats say they care about people
they don't care about these people look
I can't American lives first our I care
about American lives first but this is
also about these people I
it's all about power yeah I want to show
you it play something for you he's
booked a Pelosi earlier listen to what
Pelosi said yesterday about this issue
these newcomers make America more
American this president decided to use
it as a campaign tactic and there are
some financial and security that people
have he blamed on trade he blamed it on
immigrants and and it found a market but
I don't think that's where the American
people are people Dan just check this
out new Fox News poll just came out
immigration is the top issue for
Americans 21 percent they know it hits
their pocketbook economy 10 percent
health care nine percent climate change
sorry bado six percent race relations
five percent number one issue for the
country right now is immigration that is
not surprising imagine if the media
really reported it yeah you know what
Laura when I hear something like from
soft-spoken Nancy that she seems to care
it's almost treasonous what she's doing
selling out this country I view her as
nothing more than a slave holder because
she's in charge of not helping these
people these poor young girls these poor
young girls they're trapped in cantinas
and bars all over this country Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer responsible for
this and I tell you what I'm gonna put
out $100,000 bounty right tonight Laura
on your show I will give any Democrat
$10,000 to their favorite charity come
down to Texas and go out in no man's
land with me where these cartels drop
off these pregnant women these children
these old people and they die come with
me Democrat come from Rhode Island or
come from whatever state you want to be
from where you don't have a clue about
what's going on to Americans and people
I'll take them out I'll give them a half
a gallon of water and I'm going to see
how long they last and they're gonna
realize it's a crisis and I'll take them
to a cantina where we just rounded up 59
young girls recently and before we can
help them the drug cartel lawyers are
there to spring them and they're scared
to death to say anything this is a this
is a crisis of unbelievable portion
booted by the way Pete Buddha just says
well we're South Bend isn't full up all
you people saying the country's full up
South Bend's not full up and you got
102,000 people population in South Bay
this month we're gonna have a hundred
thousand people they estimate cross the
border illegally and touch suddenly jet
fighter spirit will take him to his town
we'll take him to his town but I'm
serious our any Democrat who wants to
come ten grand I'll tell you about no
man's I actually think about it then
challenges dropped down thank you Dan